foreign
is kicking us off in Charleston South
Carolina Griffin welcome to the show
hey guys thanks so much for having me my
dad and I are a huge fans so really
appreciate your time thank you
I want some guidance here on what to
tackle in terms of my loans or just to
keep stacking money in my savings
account currently have three main loans
between my town home student loans as
well as my car
and to break down the numbers for you
the town home was just recently
purchased 410
000 put down 10 and the current loans
for 368 535 that's not a seven year arm
at 4.75 I just paid my first mortgage on
the first of October and that was 2 365
which I own the property myself however
if you split that payment with my
girlfriend that lives with me
okay and then we've got my student we've
got my student loans um those to be
perfectly honest with you I have not
paid in a while
um but there's about six different loans
between three point seven six percent
and four point six percent and the
standing balance on that is 26 654 and
then there's the car which is a 3.69
loan
um and that total is nine thousand four
hundred and fifty five dollars and I'm
paying that every month obviously which
is a 341 dollar payment okay what's your
question
my question is I've got income of about
175 000 a year 26 and I've been
fortunate enough to be put into this
position
um do I continue to do the minimum
payments on these loans or should I pay
my car off all in one month which
basically I'm a last commission check
that I just earned I can do that
um plus save some
um I'm trying to under to try to get
some guidance here on what next steps to
take to get to the point of financials
Freedom really as quick as possible I
love it well one way to get to Financial
Freedom as quickly as possible is to
stop going into debt so are we on the
same page that there is no more debt in
the picture
no more dead in the pastry I don't have
a credit card okay great so but all the
other things are debt
the car loan the student loan the town
home so here's one thing you mentioned a
lot of interest rates which tells me you
love math
you love crunching the numbers and
justifying every purchase right
yes sir so one thing we're going to do
it's really hard for people like you who
are sharp is to ignore the interest
rates
okay now if we ignore the interest rates
and we start listing these balances from
smallest to largest that tells me that
car loan is gone this month then we're
attacking the student loans those are
going to be gone in a few more months
right and then we're going to build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and then the house that'll come
later we're not going to worry about
that part of our Consumer Debt
I should have mentioned I have 56 000 in
savings well that helps
we're debt free today my man what are
you waiting for
I should have mentioned that in a
thousand in my chapter so why are you
hanging on to the 56 and not just paying
off the debt as it's accruing interest
because the well that's a great question
I think uh a large part of it is because
I want to stay for a town home I didn't
know how much exactly I needed until I
made the purchase which was just done in
the last three or four months so that
money is really residual from the money
I was saving up for a down payment so
you decided I'm just going to put 10
down and leave the rest in the bank
the difference between the 10 to 15 and
the offer that was provided it was
really not it wasn't it didn't make
enough sense for me to do the additional
five percent so I just put 10 down
that's correct and so this is you know
what like I just said just did my first
mortgage payment so kind of in one month
one of uh owning this property and
living it okay and trying to decide what
to do with my money yeah he's spinning
plates George he's got there's actual
plates you're doing 17 things at once
number one it does worry me that
girlfriend is paying into this and she
doesn't own any part of it and if this
doesn't work out she's gonna feel like
she got screwed right
um there you know I can't speak for
anybody here um but I what I do know is
that did come to the situation by salary
alone would would pay and then my
commission on top right would would be
okay uh I would be able to pay these
other bills right so that that is I am
in that position I'll tell you what I
would do what Dave Ramsey would do if he
was sitting here and that is to be
completely debt free by the end of the
day and use the rest of the money as an
emergency fund and we're gonna then
start investing 15 of our income into
retirement any money beyond that is
going to get thrown at the mortgage and
I would probably look at refinancing
when it makes sense over to a 15-year
fixed rate because those adjustable rate
mortgages are the worst
okay very dangerous I appreciate it
so you're in a great spot we just have
to start doing things with focused
intensity one at a time but the good
news is you can do this all tomorrow if
you decide to
okay so you know in terms of that's
exactly what I wanted to hear was I feel
like I'm putting a lot of attention
towards a few different things rather
than focusing and owning it as you know
gives a gazelle intensity as they would
say towards one of these exactly I mean
you know this stuff I'm just curious how
come you haven't done it it seems like
you've been listening for a while
um I I think a lot of it is uh I am
financially conservative and I like
seeing the bank account grow there's
that level of uh Pride but then the
other the other half of it is I am 26
and I I am taking uh these steps a
little quicker than than maybe some
people would but you know there's no
excuse for that I'm I'm ready to tackle
this and make it moves tomorrow so well
your greatest well-filling tool is your
income you make an amazing income at 26
of 175 000 and I just want to see it
work for you instead of it disappear
into the abyss and you're going I don't
feel like I'm making great progress uh I
I'm listening in here I'm listening
intently Coach Ken jump in I'm going to
uh I I think you have been tinkering
because you like finances
um I think you like strategies and
that's going to make you uh susceptible
and into Temptations to Tinker and so
here's my Coach Ken my Coach Ken phrase
stop tinkering
and start focusing focus on the baby
steps the way George laid them out
you've been listening to the show just
focus on the baby steps stop tinkering
around you know what I mean just start
you're going to get further you're going
to get further with Focus right and uh
and now you you know you can always be
curious and see what options are for you
long term but that's after you get
yourself in a financially stable
situation you got it
yes sir absolutely
have you read The Total Money Makeover
Griffin
I haven't but I'm going to well can I
send it to you or do you already have a
copy
I don't have a copy but now you do boom
we're gonna ship it to you my man hang
on the line Austin will pick up and we
will send you a copy of The Total Money
Makeover that book gets me pumped every
time I still read it once a year just to
stay focused and stay motivated the
audiobook is great too so hang on the
line we'll get that to you but right now
focus is the operative word here and you
make a great income at a young age and
if you can use it and channel it like a
laser dude you can do some amazing
things with your money stop tinkering
start focusing I was hoping for a pretty
smart chalkboard I was really hoping for
a team on a chalkboard right there all
right I'll take it Ken all right pretty
good tweet that